hey this is John dallona with Ramsey
solutions we are back every once in a
while all of your dreams come true at
the same time and you put a phone call
in I called I called some of the most
extraordinary celebrities on planet
Earth and they all must have didn't
respond to me hello he did ladies and
gentlemen this is Anthony O'Neill
world-famous he has 11 trillion
followers on the youtubes and things
even the fanciest people I've ever had a
chance to meet with so here's what we're
doing we're following up from last week
talking about all the transitions all
the grief and then really who we're
gonna become on the back end of all this
and that we get to decide the next steps
are gonna take so we've got three
questions we're gonna we're gonna break
this up over the next couple of days and
so I'm gonna ask question number one -
my main man Anthony O'Neil Ramsey
personality best-selling author super
famous it's awesome okay so here's
number one real what is some things that
you learned about yourself being locked
up at home for the last eight weeks mmm
like for real for mm-hmm
this crew like I don't know about your
people in your show they can smell it
coming a mile away you gotta be honest
or though I think that one of the things
that I learned about myself that I
honestly didn't like being transparent
was I am impatient
okay and when I am impatient I am I
could be very rude you know and so I
didn't I don't like that you know I knew
that I had a problem with waiting but I
didn't know how bad it was who got it
who is the recipient of the impatient
part probably my team here okay you know
after that like so you're impatient
people here but that the anger
displacement that frustration
oh man who got that got that the
offshoot man probably my family mmm yeah
just my family in loved ones just just
not really lashing out but just lie or
whatever just just forget it but I
really realized that
you know when I see something I went it
down to right now if I can do something
better I need to do it right now and you
better not stop me okay and I like it
from the perspective of I love to work
but at the same time when I have a team
when I have family when I have loved
ones I still have to be respectful in
that area and so I learned that also I
learned
yeah and counseling usually the first
question they get is your defense
question I mean the first answer is
defense yeah so it's a real one okay one
thing that I learned about myself was
man to be real on your show having said
it so my show yet I'm lonely man yep I'm
lonely you know if you asked me today on
a scale one to ten how are you when it
comes to ten you're happy being single
one you're like I'm tired of this I'm a
five like I'm right there in the middle
and I don't like it eight weeks by
myself house you know I'm like man and
god I'm ready for a son I'm ready for a
daughter I'm ready to be a husband I'm
ready to be a provider but I was
covering that up because I was on the
road automaticity yeah you know because
I was in office all the time I was
traveling and speaking and inspiring
people but I really wasn't speaking and
inspiring myself I didn't I haven't
really built a true community being here
in Nashville I got here and went
straight to work
so I the research would tell me that
eight weeks by yourself make you go
crazy I my family left and I have to
spent a little over one week mmm man I
felt part my gosh I start sleeping all
crazy
I'll just eating burritos every like I
just yeah when I get out your family
yeah so I can't even wrap my head around
eight weeks Wow yeah so what's your and
I the the loneliness part I realize I've
been here for two years in Nashville
yeah I don't have I got I've got great
co-workers absolutely I got awesome
people in my church yeah I never see
friends at a date you know I mean I got
a be intentional about that we'll talk
about that another thing okay
what's one less that one more thing you
learn
don't enough to be deep doesn't have to
be deep hmm oh man you know being at
home
I couldn't get my meal plans so I
learned that I cannot do dairy oh yeah I
can't I just can't do milk milk stuff it
just messes up my stomach no gluten no
dairy ladies an gentlemen you heard it
first right here this is dr. John
Delaney my good friend Anthony we'll be
back in just a minute we're gonna be
wearing the same clothes because that's
just what we do here and we'll talk to
you soon subscribe to the stuff go to
Anthony's site here and I'm just
pointing to stuff because they're gonna
put the buttons up um subscribe to the
show he's got 8 trillion Eva's in Egypt
was your subscription that's a safe
prescription but follow him anyway and
we'll see you soon take care